want to talk to him for example about
the instinct to imitate because you were
talking earlier about something that
unites us you know
so imagine this for example
you know that
the same person can be
admired by a lot of different people
even people who differ in their
political beliefs
and that that admiration sort of
captures them that's charisma that's
part of charisma
the charisma is part of an instinct
right because if i think you're
charismatic and then i'm going to watch
you more my eyes are going to point to
you more i'm going to be more likely to
do the things you do i'm more likely to
imitate you
and so i would say there's something
like a central spirit that we're all
driven to imitate
and it's the thing that we see as
admirable across people
and that points to something that we
experience as religious
so like the ultimate
expression
of that which is
that which compels imitation is
indistinguishable from religious worship
it's not propositional
yeah well that's a vervakian argument
yes yes yes absolutely well and
verveiki's one of the people
who've who's thought this sort of thing
through mo in most detail
jonathan pagio as well and i know you
had him did he make the cut of your film
yeah in the director's cut so just
watching yeah if you'd like to watch the
film it's best to go to
betterleftonsetfilm.com
because over there instead of itunes and
youtube and so on which you can also get
it from if you like if that's easier but
you can go to the url better left unsaid
film dot com because over there for the
same price you get access to the
director's cut which has jonathan pajot
and i'm sure the listeners the watchers
of this are fans of jonathan
yeah well i think peugeot is super smart
man he's deep and the same with verveiki
those two
they they've taken
certain forms of thought farther than
anybody i've ever met verveiki is so
well
read it's terrifying and how's your
pajamas this weird character because
he's he's he really understood what he
knows he's thinking
yeah yeah yeah well you see
well that's part of having an artistic
temperament too you know people like
that who are more open in trait terms
they can they can see patterns in things
now that can lead them astray because
you can you can project patterns into
you know the void let's say that aren't
there that's conspiratorial thinking for
example but
intuitive people
who are also capable of critical
thinking pick up patterns long before
anyone else does i've had graduate
students like that you know they would
leap to a scientific conclusion
that was dead on multiple times and then
they'd when they were writing their
papers they'd have to uh fill in how
they got there well that wasn't how they
got there they leaped from mountaintop
to mountaintop using nichi's terminology
and they could see patterns and then
they they had to construct a rational
story to publish their ideas in
scientific journals it's so funny
because it's a form of falsification
right that isn't how they got there but
but that's so that's one of the
questions i want to ask dawkins is like
well what about this instinct to imitate
do you think such a thing exists
you know because i don't believe he's a
blank slate theorist
and we're really good at abstracting out
things to imitate and so i started
thinking about this for example when i
was watching my kids play house
so my son would act out the father you
know he'd be the father but he wasn't
imitating me exactly he wasn't mimicking
the exact gestures of my body right like
i do this while i'm imitating you right
now
but if i was a comedian and i want to
parody you i would imitate your spirit
in some sense right and then put a twist
in it and everyone would laugh so i can
abstract out from you your pattern well
then imagine we're way better at it than
that like if i watched 10 admirable men
and was gripped by my admiration for
them let's say i was fortunate enough to
have 10 admirable men in my family i
could abstract out the central spirit
that makes them all admirable and i
could imitate that
so what occurs when you keep doing that
over and over that's exactly right
across generations and so now partly
what occurs is the imagination
formulates the representation of the
abstraction
so i'll give you an example so if you
look and you often see this in byzantine
cathedral so you look up in a byzantine
cathedral it's a dome so that's the sky
and maybe you'll see an image of christ
up there as panto crater great creator
of the world this is sort of tied with
the idea that consciousness gives rise
to reality it's it's so it's an
idealistic philosophy or experience
well the idea is something like
that
the thing to be admired it's the central
phenomena and function of consciousness
and in some sense it gives rise to re to
the reality that it is good that is good
itself
and the imagination gets their way
before the propositional philosophers
way before the artists and the religious
dreamers
you made an argument that that is
partly at least what is a religious
phenomenon now do you think that's only
it
no
i have another definition that i'm
working out okay so
it these are things i'm going to talk
about when i go to cambridge because i'm
going there to oxford and cambridge at
the end of november and
in any case
so i'm also really interested in the
idea of depth
so we all have an intuition of yeah
depth d e p p pth like philosophical
depth or literary depth or or the depth
of a conversation you know and if you
have a deep conversation you know you're
talking about weighty serious yeah
fundamental things okay well i have a
technical definition for that
we we have a hierarchy of beliefs
okay some beliefs have more beliefs
dependent on them than others
the more beliefs that are dependent on a
given belief the deeper that belief is
the deepest of those beliefs
we hold sacred by definition
by definition
our deepest beliefs are sacred their
their primary and you can tell that in
part because if they're challenged
you get unbelievably upset and the
reason you get upset is because well
you're not just destabilizing that
belief you're destabilizing all the
beliefs that depend on it and so
one
sacred belief in a marriage is uh
sexual fidelity let's say faithfulness
right and you kind of take that on faith
because while you take it's own faith
that you think that's valuable
in part but it's also on faith that your
partner is manifesting that
because you you know
all you have to do is get paranoid
and then you've you can accumulate
evidence that your partner isn't
trustworthy and no one's perfectly
trustworthy so you could see how right
exactly so but it's a fundamental belief
and then if you find out that your
partner's betrayed you well then the
whole house of cards perhaps not the
whole house of cards but a lot of the
cards come tumbling down you know
the past is no longer what you thought
it was
your whole faith in humanity itself
might be compromised including your
faith in yourself like it can really
it's a dagger in the depths especially
if you really
love the person and really trusted them
so
so say the more sacred a belief is the
deeper it is embedded in this
in this structure of beliefs and i don't
believe those are objective beliefs
that's another thing i want to talk to
talkings about i do not think the
scientific evidence suggests
that
our perceptions
that what we perceive are material
objects
that are self-evident that we then
derive our conceptual systems from i
don't think there's any evidence for
that i think it's wrong and it's been
proven wrong
so you know that's some of the places i
want to go
yeah tell me what you think of this now
i've only thought about this recently
i think when atheists
call the religious dogmedic what they
truly mean is that you're pantheistic
for low-level gods what i mean is
you what you've outlined is something
like this so let's say you have a
hierarchy and hopefully it's
monotheistic in the sense that you're
integrated which no one is but hopefully
it's you're pointing to one god one
source of good okay then you're like
well what makes me good and you keep
going down and down and down until you
get to extremely micro level actions
such as
type this email i'm typing this email
why so that i can get an approval for
someone for an interview why so that i
can talk and hopefully so on and so on
and so on and i think
i think you've outlined i'm pretty sure
it was you that it depends on so which
level there's the destruction that is
proportional to the anxiety that you
experience
okay that's exactly right so then i
think we know the neurophysiology of
that even
okay so then when
someone like sam harris calls someone
else
dogmatic
essentially what they mean is that why
are you getting upset at this level why
are you holding this to be sacred
so here's another example to people who
are fundamental in their religious views
so they believe it's literal what's in
the bible is literal something i think
about is and even people who think the
bible is entirely metaphorical if i say
well what if let's imagine i'm speaking
to a fundamentalist if i say what if
this aspect of the bible is not meant to
be literals metaphorical they get upset
why do you get upset why is your belief
in god contingent should your belief in
god be contingent or should you have
faith no matter what
okay so then they would say well well so
why does that undermine your belief to
me faith
should be
well it shouldn't be so easily
undermined
and so in some sense it's as if they're
saying here is my god instead of at the
top level well here what oh yeah they
are well here okay well so let's dig
into that a little bit that's a very
good observation well
one of their unrecognized gods is
literally
the the phrase itself
because literal means real
and it means ultimately real but literal
doesn't mean real or ultimately real
necessarily
like literals really like
what does a dostoevsky novel literally
mean
well nothing
well none of it's true
it didn't happen or did it or did it
really happen like at a meta level well
that's where great novels happen is at a
meta level so truth is complicated and
this is see so the fundamentalists
they're they're tripped up
philosophically to some degree because
they
they they can't see how something can be
oh my god it's so complicated this is
where sam harris and i kept going off on
you know different tangents
they don't know what they mean when they
say literal they equate literal with
real they create real with material real
like and so when you go after that and
you say well it's not literally true
what you're saying what you're
essentially saying is that well your
whole belief system is predicated on a
misapprehension
even about the nature of god let's say
i mean you know most religious
traditions many religious traditions
insist that
representing god in a concrete manner is
actually
an error
the taoists are not very happy with that
idea that muslims certainly aren't uh
the orthodox christians really don't
many of them really don't like to
represent god the father in their
iconography and part of the reason for
that is that
you shouldn't concretize the absolute
it's it's dangerous now it's a problem
because if you don't concretize it you
can't act it out yeah yeah see i was
downtown in toronto and i i just talked
to someone and his he's this jamaican
guy so if you've well probably won't
happen now it's too cold he was cutting
coconuts and selling it and i said hey
by the way what's your name he said kurt
i'm like oh my god i rarely meet people
whose name's name is kurt and he's from
the caribbean and i walked away and i
remember thinking uh he has my name and
then i remember stopping thinking no no
he's much older i have his name then i
thought
probably what's better to say is we
share the same name and then i thought
ah okay what is it that we all share and
is that somehow related is that not
synonymous with god
what is it that we all share